-Guys, it can be hard
to say goodbye,
but sometimes you have to,
and there are a few things
I'd like to say goodbye to
right now.
It's time for "Go On, Git!"
-♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, git ♪
♪ Go on, go on, go on, git ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, paper straws.
I'll tip my hat to what you're
doing for the environment,
but you got a three-sip maximum
before you fold
like wet origami.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Go on, git, paper straws.
For something you can't suck,
you sure do suck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Spit, clang ]
-Go on, git...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...true-crime documentaries...
[ Laughter ]
...where the mystery
isn't solved at the end.
[ Laughter ]
I just binged nine
hour-long episodes,
and you're telling me
you don't even have a guess
as to who the killer is?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, now I'm just scared.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause now there's some
crazy killer on the loose,
and he knows that I know
everything he did.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be a dead man if it wasn't
for my Ring doorbell alarm.
[ Laughter ]
Now, go on, git.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git...
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
Go on, git.
It was just going all the way
down my throat, and it was --
[ Laughter ]
Go on, git, people who say every
firework is their favorite.
You do know how fireworks shows
are structured, right?
They get progressively better
as the show goes on.
They don't start
with the best fireworks.
That's like Train opening their
concert with "Drops of Jupiter."
Ain't gonna happen.
[ Laughter ]
So go on, "ooh,"
and git, "ahh."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Go on, git, kidney bean-shaped
swimming pools.
[ Laughter ]
What, being a rectangle
ain't good enough for you?
[ Laughter ]
A circle not cool enough?
No, you just get to have
all the attention, don't you?
And by the way, the human kidney
is an organ
designed to create urine.
[ Laughter ]
And that is the last thing
I want to be thinking about
before cannonballing
into the deep end.
[ Laughter ]
So go on, git,
kidney-shaped swimming pools.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unless you're in
my neighbor's backyard.
Then I'm coming over.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-G--
[ Laughter ]
-Go on, git...
screen doors with locks.
[ Laughter ]
Let me get this straight.
You're supposed
to protect my home?
So if a burglar shows up,
they're gonna be like,
"They -- they -- they got
a screen door, fellas.
Pack it in!"
[ Laughter ]
You're absolutely impenetrable
unless someone has the strength
to press through a tea bag.
[ Laughter ]
So, reach in, finger-flick
that tiny little lock
that doesn't do nothing,
come on in, and then go git.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Go on, git...
[ Laughter ]
...people asking me if I --
I can hardly talk.
Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
That's not chaw.
It's just a wad of napkins.
[ Laughter ]
Go on, git, people asking me
if I have plans
for the Fourth of July.
If'n I did,
and if'n you were included,
I'm pretty sure
you'd know by now.
[ Laughter ]
So, if I happen to see you
at Dave's barbecue,
I'd say two things to you --
"Happy birthday, 'Merica,"
and "Go on, git!"
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Spit, clang ]
[ Laughter ]
Go on, git,
"My money don't jiggle jiggle."
You had your time,
but guess what --
your aunt done ruined it by
posting about it on Facebook.
It's been real,
but you've tik'd your last tok.
So take a hike,
"My money don't jiggle jiggle,"
and say hi to "cheugy"
and "bing bong" on the way out.
Go on, sheesh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
So hard to see 'em go,
but I'm glad I got that
all out of my system.
My thanks to Steve Carell.
We'll be talking with him
after the break.